[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring on mike florio pro football
talk live co-host
mike i'm sorry for that
what's he going to do when it's 2 22
this afternoon that's what i want
2 22 on 2 22.
his head's going to explode
um thanks for joining us uh walk us
through this being an attorney um what
is the lawsuit about
let's start there well the lawsuit is
about specifically
brian flores being fired by the dolphins
when he believes he shouldn't have been
and also not being hired by the giants
or being given a fair opportunity
to compete for the giants job more
broadly it is a referendum on
the nfl's decades-long issue
with racial bias in the hiring of
coaches hiring of coaches retention of
coaches compensation of coaches black
coaches obviously
opportunities available for them
as head coaches then executives black
executives not becoming general managers
just the failures that have been hiding
in plain sight for years the failures
that brought about the rooney rule 20
years ago was the threat of litigation
not actual litigation from the late
johnny cochran and cyrus mary that got
the nfl to adopt the rooney rule here we
are 20 years later
not much progress has been made
and
the thing that
will i think spur change for the nfl is
the thing that they never thought they
would have to deal with someone coming
forward
trading his career because as a
practical matter he goes into this
knowing the risk he's taking he's
trading his career
for the opportunity to be the one who
affects meaningful permanent change for
the nfl
suing the broncos the giants
the nfl is that all
is that separate or all is it collective
uh civil lawsuit well the dolphins are
part of it as well and it's an attack on
the entire structure the entire system
now he can specifically point to
incidents with
the dolphins
he was held to a different standard he
was held to a higher standard he was
fired when he shouldn't have been he's
regarded as the angry black man who must
be dealt with instead of the demanding
head coach who is going to lead the team
to victory that's the perception that
may be the reality that's what the case
will try to prove
in denver
he claims he had a sham interview in
2019 that's why they are in the lawsuit
and in new york he contends that
he had a sham interview last week that
they knew they were hiring brian dayball
before they even brought him in for the
interview as evidenced he believes by an
accidental text message that was sent by
bill belichick of all people
to brian
just brian dabal instead of brian flores
you know i still go back to the dolphins
if
you know he
the giants said that they hired the more
qualified guy brian davil and i go how
can you possibly say that flores has
been a coach head coach in the nfl he
worked for an owner who wanted him to
lose and he still won
how are you telling me dabo is more
qualified
that that you know that's a pretty good
line on the resume
had back-to-back winning seasons despite
being employed by a guy who wanted me to
lose
uh but you're right dan look every time
a coordinator becomes a head coach
there's a risk that is being taken
that the coordinator who steps into a
very different job won't be able to do
the job but brian flores
we've seen it he's done it
he swept the patriots in 2021 for crying
out loud so he's proven he can make the
adjustment from coordinator to head
coach he's more qualified than brian
dabo from that perspective but the
dolphins thing is fascinating too and
this needs to get proper attention and
scrutiny
this this idea
that and it's an allegation i know
but that stephen ross offered brian
flores 100 000 per loss in 2019 when i
believe that stephen ross was trying to
do a full season tank to get the number
one pick in 2020 originally he wanted
tua then he fell in love with joe burrow
how does the nfl not aggressively
investigate that and if any of it is
even remotely true immediately eject
stephen ross from club oligarch
well i don't know how you prove it but
to have you know a number like not hey
offered me money he offered me one
hundred thousand dollars did flores
corroborate that story with his
assistant coaches or anybody else is
there a paper trail there i was told by
a source this morning mike it said look
you know there are repercussions with
racism and the hiring practices
this could be bigger than that story
because ross could lose his team and the
gambling allegation he is he would be
fixing games i mean i i don't think it's
hard to connect the dots of an owner
saying to your coach
i want you to lose
yeah right it's fixing games not for the
purposes of fixing games tim donahue's
style it's fixing games with a broader
strategic objective in mind we're gonna
take our lumps we're gonna be bad all of
2019 not just once we know we're not a
playoff team we know we're not a playoff
team going in let's just go ahead and be
as bad as we can to secure a prime
position in the draft next year so i can
finally get the next dan moreno for this
team that was the plan i believe for
stephen ross in 2019
and you know the the the
the difference doesn't matter if you're
trying to lose in an environment where
the nfl has partnerships with seven
different sports books and gambling is
spreading everywhere
everyone has to be trying to win
every game and this is going to spark a
broader conversation i believe about the
connection between draft position
and losing games late in the season when
you're out of the playoffs they need to
find a way to take away the incentive to
lose because it's there it's there and
teams have done it from time to time
they do it adroitly they cover their
tracks
but the incentive is obvious to try to
lose games once you know you're not in
the playoffs you get a better spot when
it's time to pick the best players the
next year i'm going to play something
for you if you've ever wanted to hear
what 600 000
sounds like this is what it sounds like
this is may of 2017 when i had mark
cuban the mavericks owner and he
admitted to the mavs tanking
it's like look you know we all
you know the mavs once we were
eliminated from the playoffs we did
everything possible to lose games and so
if we did it up front if we knew that
this was a rebuilt season and we just
did it up front then you know you you
know you kind of know what kind of team
you have and if you could get eliminated
early and then start building momentum
you can finish you know your season
30 and
10
and end up with a boatload of ping-pong
balls how did you tank how do you
play all your young players okay that
was it but there is a is it uh you send
out a memo or you just say no no because
the guys once a guy walks on the court
they're going to play their heart out
particularly the young guys because they
have something to prove so you know
dorian finney smith um yogi farrell
there's nothing you could say or do to
them to say don't play hard or try to
lose this game that wouldn't be right in
and i don't think any nba team would
ever do that but when you have solid
mesri shooting threes
that's not a good thing yeah
that cost him six hundred thousand
dollars
he violated the first rule of tank club
don't talk about tank club
right but the incentive is there i mean
tell his coach to
well no but but this is how it works
you make the decision as the owner of
the team you want to evaluate the young
players you want to see how the third
string quarterback does i thought that's
what the texans were doing late in the
season when they decided to go with
davis mills over tyrod taylor they won
some games though it doesn't always work
out
but but the incentive is there the
system creates the incentive the draft
the way they do the draft creates the
incentive and the nfl never wants to
acknowledge the obvious connection
between losing once you're done like
mark cuban said and rising
in the opportunity to get the
potentially generational talent that
transforms your team it's obvious and
you know i've been kicking around some
ideas on what to do about it there's no
easy solution the easiest solution to
get rid of the draft they're never going
to do that
but there's got to be a way to remove
the incentive to lose
because the incentive to lose is there
when you look at the draft order and you
look at how much it's given up look at
what the 49ers gave up to go from 12 to
three last year two more first round
picks and a third round pick every year
significant assets are surrendered to go
a little bit higher hey if we just would
have lost this game or this game chase
young would be a giant if the giants had
lost to washington week 17 at the
2019 season so
there's a real benefit to it and they
just need to remove the incentive and
and this is how it's biting them in the
butt and it'll be interesting to see
whether they take it seriously and
investigate it or look the other way dan
i think they're going to brush it under
the rug i think they've got too much
that can happen
to the nfl collectively congress on the
scene potentially they're going to rally
around stephen ross and they're going to
brush the brush this underwear i hope
i'm wrong i never have hoped that i am
more wrong than i am right now about it
i hope they take it seriously my my
guess is
they can't because the ramifications are
too significant it's mike florio pro
football talk live co-host why isn't
there a union for coaches in the nfl
well because coaches don't want to trade
their careers for signing a union card
and with only 32 teams and so many more
qualified individuals who could come in
and become even if they're not good
coaches right out of the gates they
could grow into the job supply outweighs
demand the coaches would never come
together and create the union it also
becomes complicated when you become a
head coach
because head coach is management i think
the union would consist of assistant
coaches then you'd exit the union when
you become a head coach but that's part
of the problem it's part of the problem
talk to sean payton about bountygate and
it becomes crystal clear the difference
between having a union which fought and
beat back
all of the player suspensions and being
a coach
and having no rights the commissioner
suspended you well i want to appeal it
okay you appeal it to the commissioner
appeal denied see you next year uh jim
harbaugh i don't think gets on that
plane unless when he gets off he's
expected to be the head coach of the
minnesota vikings what do you think
he wants to come back to the nfl he
wants to win a super bowl he has to deal
with the fact that his brother john won
the one that jim thought he was going to
win in 2012. and he's got an ally there
and the new general manager question
mensah whatever happened in san
francisco however it went sideways
between jim harbaugh and former 49ers
general manager trent bowkey however
ownership was involved in the
dysfunction
adofo mensah was there for the last two
years of harbaugh's time there
and whatever he saw whatever he
witnessed whatever he observed and
experienced
put harbaugh at the top of his list of
coaches to hire when he becomes a
general manager that tells you something
and i think the vikings are a little bit
leery about harbaugh there's a sense
that maybe he's got to win the job today
in the interview
and you know you just got to ask
yourself do you want a guy that was 44
19 and one in four seasons do you want a
guy that took a team that was six and
ten
with no offseason program because of the
lockout in 2011 and took his team to the
brink of the super bowl but for a couple
of muff punts by kyle williams they
would have been in the super bowl that
year it was an amazing turnaround that's
what the wilson have to ask themselves
do we want to roll the dice on a guy who
has shown he can do it or do we want to
roll the guy dice on a guy who has never
even had a head coaching job before i
didn't even ask you about tom brady do
you think tom
left out acknowledging the patriots on
purpose
there is no way that that multi-page
statement was something he thumbed on
his iphone sitting on the toilet
yesterday morning that thing was written
and rewritten and revised and vetted and
everything in there was there for a
reason everything not in there was not
in there for a reason i think it was
deliberate whatever the reason whatever
the reason i don't know you know people
think he's going to show up at gillette
stadium and do a one-day contract and
he'll do his
patriots victory lap then who knows but
it really was glaring to see pretty much
every one in the buccaneers organization
thanked
and no mention of the patriots
whatsoever you okay with the washington
commanders
i'm okay with the fact that the name
isn't what it used to be
and
i was fine with washington football team
yeah i don't like the uniforms but you
know i i like i like the old school
uniforms i love it when the raiders and
the cowboys play when the browns and the
packers play
the nikefication of the nfl continues
and we have a a new set of jerseys that
can be purchased for
199.99 at nflshop.com please buy them
now and buy them quickly because in two
years they'll be changing again
good stuff thank you mike great to talk
to you talking to you dan
mike florio pro football talk